en el último vídeo introduje el criterio
de la segunda derivada en donde si
tienes una función de varias variables
digamos una función x por el momento
pensemos en una función f que depende
sólo de xy de ye y cuando buscamos
sitios en donde haya máximos o mínimos o
quizás puntos y ya lo primero que hay
que buscar son aquellos puntos donde el
gradiente se anule es decir donde el
gradiente de la función sea justamente
el vector cero verdad ya estos puntos en
donde esto ocurre les llamamos puntos
críticos pero en realidad esto de que el
gradiente sea cero es una forma compacta
de decir que las primeras derivadas
parciales se anula en verdad sean igual
a cero y para determinar si es un máximo
o quizás un mínimo o un punto sí ya sin
sin ver necesariamente la gráfica porque
no siempre vamos a tener una gráfica a
la mano entonces el primer paso es
tratar de calcular esta expresión ok en
donde en realidad estamos tomando las
tres derivadas parciales del segundo
en verdad y por supuesto evaluamos estás
derivadas en el punto crítico y vemos
que hay una especie de disputa verdad
entre los términos que se multiplican
aquí que son la segunda derivada de f
con respecto de x ambas veces por la
segunda derivada de f con respecto de
ambas veces y luego restamos la derivada
parcial mixta verdad es decir la
derivada de f respecto de x y luego
respecto de ye pero esto va elevado al
cuadrado verdad entonces todo esto va
evaluado en el punto crítico verdad y si
obtenemos que a digamos que este valor h
es positivo es decir es mayor que 0
entonces lo que tenemos es un máximo o
podríamos tener un valor mínimo muy bien
y en realidad para determinar cuál de
estos dos puede ser entonces simplemente
tenemos que checar la concavidad digamos
con este término por ejemplo podríamos
considerar este término y entonces si la
segunda derivada de f con respecto de x
ambas veces es positivo quiere decir que
en la d
x esto se verá algo más o menos así
verdad es algo que es cóncava hacia
arriba y en cuyo caso tendríamos un
mínimo pero si la segunda derivada de f
con respecto de x fuera negativa
entonces tendríamos esta figurita verdad
en donde la concavidad es hacia abajo y
por lo tanto el punto crítico sería un
máximo local verdad entonces bueno vamos
a borrar por el momento esto que
teníamos aquí y en el caso en el que
tengamos una un valor de h negativo
entonces estamos en el caso en donde
tenemos un punto silla un punto silla
que es justamente en donde no podríamos
decir que es un máximo de es decir por
un lado es un máximo pero por otro lado
es un mínimo verdad y tenemos un último
caso justo cuando no es ninguno de estos
dos es decir cuando h es igual a cero y
desafortunadamente en este caso no
podemos garantizar nada en realidad el
método o el criterio no nos sirve y
habría que buscar por nuestra propia
cuenta si es un máximo mínimo o un punto
silla
la pregunta es por qué este criterio
funciona así que vamos a analizar cada
término individualmente entonces aquí
tenemos la segunda derivada de f con
respecto de x ambas veces verdad y
entonces aquí estamos pensando digamos
en en toda la función como si x fuera la
única variable es decir sólo nos vamos a
mover en la dirección de x verdad y en
términos de la gráfica podemos pensar
que estamos cortando con un plano que va
en la dirección de x es decir el valor
de ye es constante y esto nos da una
curva al intersectar la gráfica con este
plano verdad y vemos por ejemplo en este
caso que la concavidad es hacia arriba
verdad entonces en esencia esta segunda
derivada parcial lo que nos dice es cómo
es la concavidad la concavidad en la
dirección x en la dirección x muy bien
entonces análogamente si nosotros
tomamos la segunda derivada de f con
respecto de ambas veces
estamos pensando como si la función sólo
dependiera de verdad entonces si nos
movemos solo en la dirección de jay y
esto sería digamos como si intersectar
amos a la gráfica con un plano que se
mueve en la dirección y es decir con un
valor constante de x verdad entonces
esto nos da una curva que podemos ver
que tiene cierta concavidad verdad y por
supuesto en este caso vemos que la
concavidad es hacia arriba entonces
podemos pensar que esto nos mide la
concavidad en la dirección de verdad
sobre la curva que obtenemos al
intersectar con el plano muy bien ahora
pensemos que la concavidad digamos en la
dirección x y la concavidad en la
dirección ya fueran distintas muy bien
entonces vamos a hacer el análisis por
aquí digamos que la concavidad en x es
decir esta segunda derivada parcial
respecto de x ambas veces fuera positiva
verdad pero que esta derivada con
respecto de ambas veces fuera negativa
entonces podemos ver que este producto
verdad nos va
a dar algo negativo pero ahora tenemos
que restar una un término verdad que de
hecho siempre va a ser no negativo es
decir va a ser mayor o igual que 0
porque lo tenemos elevado al cuadrado
entonces aquí lo que obtenemos es un
producto que es negativo y luego regles
le restamos algo que es positivo
entonces siempre vamos a tener algo
negativo y por supuesto estaríamos
hablando del caso en que tenemos un
punto silla verdad y quizás el ejemplo
por excelencia de esto es justamente la
función f x igual a x cuadrada menos y
cuadrada este es como el ejemplo por
excelencia y aquí tenemos la gráfica de
esta función verdad aquí tenemos la
gráfica y podemos ver que si nos movemos
únicamente en la dirección de x entonces
tendremos concavidad hacia arriba y si
ahora digamos nos movemos mejor en la
dirección de iu entonces tenemos
concavidad hacia abajo y esto coincide
muy bien con el signo negativo que
tenemos en él
de cuadrada verdad entonces este fue el
caso en que ambos difieren pero qué
pasaría si ahora coincidieran es decir
qué pasaría si en lugar de tener signos
contrarios ahora tuvieran signos iguales
puede ser que ambos sean positivos o
bien ambos sean negativos verdad
entonces en realidad este producto en
ambos casos sería positivo verdad y esto
captura muy bien que coincidan verdad si
el valor es positivo de este producto
quiere decir que coinciden en la
concavidad pero tenemos un problema
nosotros en ambos casos tenemos que
restar este término que es siempre mayor
o igual que 0 verdad vamos a ponerle que
es positivo verdad entonces en realidad
podemos ver que se vuelve como una
especie de disputa verdad entre la
coincidencia de que tenemos de este lado
entre la coincidencia de la concavidad
en ambas direcciones y digamos el valor
que tiene esta derivada parcial del
segundo orden pero mixta
es una coincidiendo la disputa que hay
entre la coincidencia y lo que le ocurre
a la segunda derivada mixta así que
mientras más grande sea este valor esta
segunda derivada parcial entonces más
negativo va a ser este término h verdad
ahora bien veamos por qué este término
este término de aquí trata de de
decirnos que esto es un punto silla así
que fijémonos primero en la función
simple fx igual a equis porque entonces
consideremos fx y igual a la función x
porque muy bien entonces podemos ver del
lado izquierdo cuál es su gráfica aquí
la tenemos y ahora vamos a empezar a
calcular las derivadas parciales
entonces primero tendremos la derivada
parcial de f con respecto de x
si nosotros derivamos esto con respecto
de x ésta es digamos la parte variable y
entonces la derivada será simplemente y
por otro lado si derivamos ahora con
respecto de esto
esta sería la variable y esto sería
constante y por lo tanto al derivar nos
da simplemente x pero qué pasa si
nosotros ahora calculamos las segundas
derivadas parciales entonces por ejemplo
la segunda derivada de f con respecto de
x ambas veces si nosotros derivamos
respecto de x esta expresión vamos a
obtener 0 porque la derivada de ye con
respecto de x es 0 lo mismo va a pasar
con la segunda derivada de f con
respecto de y nos da 0 porque al derivar
con respecto de gec a esto que es x pues
solo nos da 0 y finalmente si nosotros
consideramos la segunda derivada digamos
mixta verdad primero derivamos respecto
de x y luego respecto de ley o bien
podríamos derivar primero respecto de y
luego respecto de x entonces es como si
derivamos esto con respecto de ye y esto
nos da 1 o como si derivamos esto con
respecto de x y también nos da una
verdad entonces con esto podemos ver que
nuestra expresión del valor de h verdad
sería cero por cero menos uno
que sería menos uno entonces otra vez
estamos en el caso donde h es negativo y
por lo tanto tendríamos un punto silla
verdad así que esta función digamos es
como una forma pura de fijarnos en cómo
se ve este término mixto verdad y si se
tuviera por ejemplo aquí un coeficiente
3 entonces todo todo ahí estaría
acompañado de un coeficiente 3 y aquí
obtendríamos al final 3 verdad en
realidad un coeficiente va cambiando el
valor digamos de esta segunda derivada
mixta verdad entonces notemos que el
hecho de que se vea como un punto si ya
no es porque x en la dirección xy en la
dirección y no coincidan de hecho
coincide en verdad pero más aún en la
dirección x en realidad se ve como
constante verdad es decir la altura si
sólo nos movemos en esta dirección la
altura es constante y eso coincide muy
bien con que la segunda derivada de f
con respecto de x ambas veces sea 0
verdad al mismo tiempo si cortamos
digamos con un plano que vaya en la
dirección de iu es decir tomando
a equis constante la altura no cambia en
la intersección verdad y corresponde al
hecho de que la segunda derivada de f
con respecto de g
también sea cero y la razón por la que
se ve como un punto silla es porque si
cortamos con un plano diagonal verdad
parece que que la intersección tiene una
concavidad hacia abajo pero digamos con
otra dirección en realidad parece que
tiene una directa una concavidad hacia
arriba así que el término xy captura
digamos la discrepancia que hay en las
direcciones diagonales verdad y algo que
quizás podría sorprender en principio es
que solo necesitamos una derivada
parcial del segundo orden para
determinar la información toda la
información de las direcciones
diagonales verdad puede puede no ser no
imaginar que podría haber discrepancias
en la dirección de dos vectores verdad y
tendríamos que considerar una infinidad
de direcciones y si lo contamos además
este término con las segundas derivadas
parciales respecto de equis y respecto
de ye entonces en real
y ya con esos tres términos se están
tomando en cuenta todas las posibles
discrepancias y esto basta para
determinar si es un punto silla o no
ahora bien si desea saber la
justificación rigurosa de esto digamos
lo he añadido en un artículo que que se
adentra en los detalles pero si quieres
pensarlo de forma digamos más intuitiva
está derivada parcial mixta verdad la
derivada parcial mixta respecto de xy
respecto de g
da una idea de qué tanto se parece la
función original a x por ye verdad que
capturan las discrepancias diagonales
así tenemos digamos una disputa entre
las coincidencias de de digamos de las
derivadas en la dirección xy en la
dirección de de y digamos también
tenemos está digamos disputa con la
discrepancia en las direcciones
diagonales verdad así que espero que
todo esto te dé una buena idea de por
qué esto es válido para tratar de
entender si es un máximo
bueno nos vemos en el próximo vídeo